Non, mais chérie, t'es en train de me dire
que je vais me marier dans un château ?
Exactement.
Non mais c'est incroyable,
t'as des plans, mais fou quoi !
Oui, c'est mon petit réseau.
Là, c'est long à expliquer.
Mais t'es la témoin parfaite,
c'est incroyable.
Moi aussi, chérie, ça me plaît beaucoup
et t'as pas vu à l'intérieur.
C'est beau !
Ouais, c'est beau...
Je suis désolée,
je suis un petit peu stressée
mais c'est parce que c'est le jour J
puis là, faut que j'aille me préparer.
Moi j'ai repéré des spots,
les photos vont être sublimes.
Oui j'espère.
Il faut que je vous montre ma robe, venez !
Là c’est ma robe qui a été faite sur...
Alice ?
Ah !
Je peux savoir ce que t'es en train là ?
Zoé ?
Heureusement que j'ai essayé ta robe de mariée.
- parce que figure-toi que
- T’es en train de mettre ma robe
sur ton Instagram ?
Quoi ?!
Pas du tout.
D'où tu sors ça Zoé ?
Tu tapes des hashtags là ?
Bon, tu sais quoi,
je vais te taguer sur la photo.
Oui, je fais ça.
Pardon, c'est...
En fait, j'arrive pas à l'enlever donc,
vas-y, aide-moi, s'il te plaît ?
Mais c'est incroyable
que t'aies fait un truc pareil !
Qu'est-ce qui t'a pris, enfin !
J’ai un peu transpiré dedans.
Oui, tu sens fort !
Je suis stressée.
Non t'inquiètes pas, ça va bien se passer.
- Comment je vais faire ?
- Mais non tout est sous contrôle
ne t’inquiètes pas.
- T’es sûr ?
- Mais oui,
j'ai ton téléphone, ton code
je lance ton live Instagram à ton arrivée,
ça va faire un carton !
Ok super, c'est quoi mon code ?
- 2632
- Parfait.
T’es la plus belle.
Papa, mais grouille-toi là !
Je vais mettre un petit filtre.
Non houla.
Pourquoi ça bug ?
Pourquoi ça s’enlève pas putain !
Y’a combien de personnes ?
Oh putain.
Supprimer, supprimer.
Voulez-vous prendre, Zoé Filipeti pour épouse ?
Oui, je le veux.
Franchement, on entend rien
pour la vidéo, il peut refaire ?
C'est possible de reprendre plus fort ?
parce que ma tante là-bas,
elle entend rien du tout.
Anthony Jean-Baptiste.
Voulez-vous prendre...
Plus fort !
Allez.
Anthony Jean-Baptiste.
Voulez-vous prendre Zoé Filipeti pour épouse ?
Oui, je le veux.
Zoé Filipeti
Voulez-vous prendre...
Allez, un avion carrément.
On reprend du départ, d’accord ?
ça vous ennuie pas.
Papa, tu viens, s'il te plaît ?
On y va là ?
Oui, la photographe est bientôt prête
elle va bombarder, ça va être magnifique.
OK, super.
Par contre, pas de lancer de riz.
Tu connais ma position
pour le gâchis alimentaire.
Du lancer de riz,
mais n'importe quoi.
J'ai 100 fois mieux que ça.
- Ok
- Vous allez être beaux.
On va faire des belles
bulles pour la photo.
Allez servez-vous.
On s'arrache les poumons,
je compte sur vous.
Ouais enfin pas trop quand même.
Je sais ce que je fais.
J'ai vu ça sur Instagram.
On est prêt ?
Tu fais des photos toi OK ?
C'est quand vous voulez !
Allez on souffle !
Oh des bulles ! J’adore !
On souffle !
C'est normal que ça pique les yeux ?
ça pique un peu.
- C'est beau les photos ?
- Chérie t’es où ?
- Je sais pas je vois pas !
- Chérie ?!
Pourquoi ça pique comme ça ?!
Parce que c'est du savon !
Elles sont belles les photos ?
Je sais pas, je vois pas, c’est flou !
CONTINUEZ DE SOUFFLER !
On est partis !
On va faire la petite photo.
Je vais demander
à la famille de se réunir.
Vous vous placez au niveau des mariés.
Super, c'est homogène, c'est magnifique,
vous êtes sublime
et on va prendre la photo.
Attends, le monsieur là,
voilà à côté du mari,
mettez-vous sur la droite, ça sera mieux.
Ouais voilà.
Mais non, c’est le parrain.
Ouais, mais sur Instagram
ça ne va pas marcher.
Donc c'est mieux comme ça. Ouais.
Mais là, ça me fait un énorme trou.
On va prendre quelqu’un d’autre.
Le Monsieur là-bas.
C'est un serveur.
C'est très bien, crois-moi.
Écoute, en plus, si on recadre,
- On ne verra pas les côtés.
- Tu t’y connais en cadre toi ?
Oui vas-y.
A trois vous dites SERVEUR !
Un, deux, trois.
SERVEUR
C'est super, c'est super.
Tu veux m'apprendre mon métier ?
Non, pas du tout.
Juste là voilà.
Mettez-le là.
Parfait, merci beaucoup.
Oh chérie c’est notre gâteau !
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est, Alice ?
C'est ton gâteau.
Mais et pourquoi y'a écrit Cochonou
partout sur mon gâteau ?
C'est ton sponsor, tu m'as dit que
tu voulais un sponsor pour ton mariage,
comme le mariage de Chiara Ferragni.
Bah voilà.
Chiara Ferragni Alison,
son sponsor, c'est Christian Dior.
Oui, Christian il répond pas.
Par contre Cochonou ils ont répondu.
C’est une catastrophe.
Non, c’est pas une catastrophe.
C'est beaucoup d'argent.
Ils financent ton mariage.
C'est pas de ma faute,
si tes parents sont fauchés.
Donc voilà, tu dois être contente.
D'ailleurs il faut faire une
petite Story pour les remercier
C’est normal.
donc voilà, mais tu mets ça,
tu te mets là. On fait une petite photo.
Voilà pour le sponsor.
Ils vont adorer.
Grand sourire,
Peut-être que si on
enlève le saucisson, c’est bon  ?
Oula non, mauvaise idée.
Je pense qu'ils en ont mis à l’intérieur.
ça doit avoir un goût sucré-salé pas ouf.
Donc à votre place je goûterai pas.
Mais je suis végétarienne.
Oui mais végétarienne,
ça rapporte pas d'argent.
Alice, il est où le DJ?
Il n'y a pas de DJ, c'est moi le DJ.
Je mets une playlist Spotify
et j'appuie sur les boutons.
Je lève les mains, les gens ils voient que du feu,
ils pensent que je suis
une grande DJette parisienne.
Je te fais économiser
500 balles de DJ.
OK !
Tu m'avais pas dit
que ta pote elle était DJ ?
Ouais je t’expliquerai !
Vous avez des fuites
urinaires très régulièrement ?
Avec la serviette Urifluide,
et sa zone super absorbante
Oubliez vos fuites urinaire.
Zoé ! T’as pas un compte premium Spotify ?
Plus de fuites urinaires avec Urifluide.
La protection sans débordements.
Pas besoin de m'expliquer et sans odeur.
et sans odeurs !
Alice, Alice, t'as pas vu Zoé ?
Non.
ça fait 1h qu'elle a disparu.
Ok, on va la trouver, ok ?
Tu disparais le jour de ton mariage.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Là, c'est quoi ça?
Alors ça c'est un bug
Parce que ton téléphone il...
Et le fait que t'essayes ma robe ?
Ou je sais pas, le gâteau
Cochonou, c'est un bug aussi ça ?
Zoé, moi j’essaye juste d’aider.
De m'aider ?
Je suis la risée d'Internet.
Et ma famille m'appelle mon petit cochon.
C'est m'aider ça tu penses ?
Zoé, mélange pas tout.
parce que déjà sans moi,
t'aurais pas eu le château.
J'en ai rien à foutre de ton château.
La seule chose que je veux
moi c'est hyper simple,
c'est être heureuse, tu vois ?
Et non, voilà
Dès que je suis avec toi
c'est les likes, les sponsors
Allez, hashtag
viens on trouve une opé !
Tu me rends dingue !
Zoé, je comprends pas
ce que t'attends de moi.
La seule chose de toi que j’attends
c'est que tu t'en ailles.
C'est pour toutes ces raisons, Zoé
Tu es la personne la plus
formidable que je connaisse
et j'espère être le meilleur mari pour toi.
Bon voilà, c'est la fin du discours chiant,
maintenant, c'est reparti pour la fête !
Zoé, je suis désolée.
Tu te rappelles quand on était au collège
on était vraiment pas les filles les plus populaires.
Tout le monde se moquait de nous.
Et toi, tu t'en foutais.
Et regarde-toi aujourd'hui
T'es la plus belle des mariées.
Et moi je ruine tous tes efforts.
J'essaie de toujours trouver une idée
pour gagner en popularité,
mais la vérité c'est que toi,
t'as pas besoin de ça.
Toi, t'as juste besoin d'être toi-même,
et voilà,
tout le monde te kiff,
tout le monde te suis,
t’es Zoé suis moi quoi.
Au début, j'étais jalouse de ça.
Et tout le monde me disait
“oui Zoé elle est plus drôle ”
“ Zoé elle est plus jolie ”
Aujourd'hui, je te vois et
je suis juste fière de toi.
Je comprendrais si tu veux plus me parler.
J'ai préparé un petit cadeau pour toi,
mais le cheval blanc est passé
par-dessus la clôture cet après-midi.
On l’a retrouvé dans du barbelé, c'est pas beau à voir.
Du coup, j'ai improvisé un petit truc,
je sais pas si ça te fera plaisir.
Attention, t’es en live sur Instagram.
Coucou Zoé, c’est Caroline Receveur.
Oh ! C'est Caroline Receveur.
Bonjour Caroline.
Ton mariage était incroyable,
vraiment bravo.
C'était magnifique.
Merci beaucoup.
Et voilà j'ai demandé à toute ma communauté
de te suivre parce que
je t'aime vraiment beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup Caroline.
Merci.
Je vous encourage aussi
à suivre mon amie Alice.
Non arrête !
@Inparisalice
Je t’embrasse.
J’étais en ligne avec Caroline Receveur !
Je suis fière de toi.
Allez, DJ va bosser.
Oui, pardon, musique !
Je suis trop contente, j’ai les deux
personnes que j’aime le plus avec moi
Oh, arrête !
Vous étiez très beaux.
Vous aussi.
Au fait, j'ai goûté le gâteau.
Non ! Et alors ?
Franchement ?
Ouais.
- Dégueulasse.
- Ah, ça me dégoute.
Ils ont mis des morceaux dedans ?
Ouais.
Oh putain, quelle idée de merde.